as you may or may not have heard today
is a sacred holiday called international
trans day of visibility
this is a day set aside to specially
affirm acknowledge recognize celebrate
trans people
and it's good that we have a day like
this because there are not enough days
on the calendar specifically dedicated
to honoring
people who identify as lgbt i mean all
we have right now is international
transgender day of visibility
and also lesbian visibility day april
26th
and uh international day against
homophobia transphobia and biphobia may
17th and of course harvey milk day may
22nd
and pansexual and pan romantic
visibility day may 24th and obviously
pride month in june followed by
bisexuality day uh september 23rd and
then obviously bisexual awareness week
september 23rd to september 30th and
national coming out day october 11th
pronouns day october 16th national lgbt
center awareness day october 19th spirit
day october 20th intersex awareness day
october 26th asexual awareness week
october 23rd through the 29th
and transgender day of remembrance
november 20th and pansexual panromantic
pride day december 8th
so you see lgbt people clearly aren't
visible enough all they have is an
entire month and a dozen other separate
holidays that's all they got
along with really every other day on the
calendar because no group of people on
earth today or at any other time in
history
have been so specially and obsessively
and incessantly recognized and
celebrated there has never been such a
mismatch between a group's size and the
population and their influence over the
culture it's an influence so extreme
that society itself is being reorganized
as we speak in order to cater to the
demands of lgbt activists every
institution in the country has made lgbt
awareness and activism its primary
priority
major corporations like disney are
willingly alienating 99 of their
customer base for the sake of lgbt
extremism
our very conception of reality itself of
human nature of biology is being
reordered and reshaped at the best of
lgbt activists
and the process isn't done because i
mean it's never done
in fact the white house unveiled today a
whole new list of initiatives to um
coincide with the trans day of
visibility charlotte climber who's a
militant trans activist with the human
rights campaign outlined all of the new
policies in a twitter thread this
morning so i'm gonna read some of this
to you it says
the white house and federal agencies put
out a number of wonderful announcements
about trans rights a few hours ago and
so i'm so excited to tell you about them
because today should be a day about
trans and non-binary
joy one the state department announced
that starting on april 11th u.s citizens
will be able to select x as a non-binary
gender marker on passports
they are the first federal agency to
codify this inclusive policy applicants
can
already self-select without medical
documentation
two tsa announced that they are updating
their body scanners at airport security
to move away from tech that has led to
trans and non-binary travelers
experiencing frequent discrimination
reducing unnecessary and invasive and
humiliating body searches so excited for
this three tsa is also working with
airlines to implement non-binary markers
during the flight booking process
removing gender considerations with
validating traveler info at airport
security including non-binary markers
during tsa pre-check enrollment and cbp
trusted traveler four department of
health and human service
services released a new website that
offers resources and guidance for lgbtq
youth and families to counteract several
gop-led state governments removing such
resources from their own websites in
recent months and five the department of
education's office of safe and
supportive schools is expanding training
with more resources to educate school
leaders and communities about the
challenges facing trans and non-binary
youth and their families
and the list goes on climber lays out
actually 13
new transaffirming initiatives from the
white house today
and notes that it's only a partial list
but let's focus for a moment on just the
first three items
you'll now be allowed to put your gender
down as x on your passport
now
the whole point of a passport of course
is to provide information about your
physical identity so that governments
can document and keep records of who is
coming and going
that's why we have passports so if
they're going to let you put x as your
gender on your passport because that's
how you feel whatever the hell it means
to feel like an ex
they might as well let you change your
date of birth to better align with your
self-perception i was born on june 18th
1986 but um
sometimes i feel like somebody who was
born on april uh fourth 1991
or you know august 7th
1948.
i feel like that sometimes
how does that feel but just it just
feels how i feel i'm asking any
questions about it
why can't i change my passport to
reflect that really if identity is fluid
then
we shouldn't have passports at all i
mean all the passport does at best is
capture my identity on the moment when i
applied for it and took the picture but
no passport can truly encapsulate the
full essence of my ever evolving being
now you might point out that this
passport change is total insanity for
many reasons
not the least of which being that the
rest of the world has not signed on to
this
your passport as an american is meant to
get you into other countries
but most other countries in the world
especially in the non-western world
do not recognize the gender of x
you're gonna have a lot of trouble
explaining your ex-gender to the customs
agent
over in iran or tanzania
has the buying administration taken that
into account
i mean have they coordinated with every
other government in the world to make
sure that this is going to be recognized
well of course not
these are important practical concerns
but important practical concerns have no
weight when stacked up against a trans
person's desire to be affirmed
and as established
all of human society must be reorganized
for that purpose
it's our highest purpose as a
civilization it's our only purpose
that's why we're all here did you know
that
it's just to affirm lgbt people it's
your it's the only reason you exist
now
that explains why all of these changes
are also being made to the airport
screening process now at least the
change is there
if if this actually happens they reduce
the airport strip searches
make the screening process less invasive
etc those are mostly positive
i mean that's assuming that this will be
the case for everybody and not just
trans people
they're making it less invasive for
everybody if that's the case that's a
big if then i would call that a positive
change but consider the fact
that travelers at american airports have
been treated like suspected drug
smugglers and terrorists for 20 years i
mean for 20 years just the simple fact
that you want to
get on a delta airlines flight and you
know fly to um
uh cincinnati or something that alone
meant that you are suspected of
terrorism and they're going to treat you
as if they have reasonable suspicion of
a crime so they're going to do all these
searches and everything else
so they've been doing that for 20 years
they've been doing pat downs on old
ladies in wheelchairs and making kids
remove their shoes in case the you know
the
little nine-year-old is sneaking
explosives and his velcro nikes
they've been doing all of this for
multiple decades no matter how much we
complained about it but all it took was
a few trans people feeling uncomfortable
and suddenly the whole system is being
retooled
you know you had an old lady complains
about it and they say shut up granny
but then a trans person complains and
they say oh no i'm so sorry well here
let's just completely change everything
for your sake i'm sorry to have offended
you please forgive us
if that's not privilege and power i
don't know what is
now those in the audience who are a
little bit younger and only became
politically aware a few years ago
or maybe people who are older and still
only became politically aware a few
years ago may be surprised to learn
that lgbt activism at least in the
mainstream had a much different tone as
recently as eight or nine years ago
there have always been the militant
factions and now there are only militant
factions but up until recently
the lgbt rights quote unquote movement
marched under banners that said things
like you know we just want to be left
alone and what two consenting adults do
in their bedrooms doesn't affect you
and uh we just want tolerance
now the more perceptive among us such as
yours truly uh recognized at the time
that these claims and slogans were
nothing but a cover story but lots of
people took it all at face value
believing that the activists really just
wanted to live their own lives and peace
and nothing more
those people have been taken by surprise
now shocked to learn that actually what
the activists want
is not to be left alone or to be
tolerated but to have all of society
our laws our institutions our lives
revolve around them
and their desires
and now
everyone is finally learning that fact
but it's a little late in the game
unfortunately
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends